hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
I'm a property investor I've been in the
market now full time for 14 years and in
this video I want to talk about is
property a good investment right now in
2023. what a house price is going to do
and how can you predict the housing
market so let me tell you something
interesting what most people do is most
people buy with emotions and they
normally take advice from the smart one
in their family you know maybe it's
their uncle that watches the news and
pays attention to what's going on and
they'll say what do you think Unk is now
a good time the problem with that is if
you've got a smart uncle in the family
that watches the news the newspapers I
mean I'm just reading the newspapers
right now BBC last week said house price
rise in April in Surprise rise and
they're talking about how prices are
going up right now and in April they
just went up by 0.5 but then literally
two three days later the newspapers will
suddenly change their story this one was
published this morning it says there is
a ticking time bomb in the housing
market a crash could still be on the
horizon so what happens is people get
really emotional and fearful and excited
when emotions are high intelligence is
low so instead of buying off what the
newspapers say the newspapers are
literally trying to sell stories they
know that if they can trigger a reaction
of excitement or outrage or fear
scarcity that's gonna get clicks so I
would really encourage you not to read
the newspapers and to get your advice on
the newspapers instead study economics
and study history I've been in the
market for 14 years I've seen three
recessions well I started during the
Great Recession 2008 2009 crash then in
2020 we had a recession during the
pandemic and we're in a recession right
now so I've not just got experience from
the 14 years I've been in property but
I've also looked back over the last 50
100 years in the property market and let
me give you a quick history lesson
property prices tend to go up
and then they go down and then they go
up and then they go down and that the
higher the up
then the bigger the down
and this is tends to be how they go up
now on average if you look back over the
last hundred years property prices
double in value every 10 years now you
might think oh come on they're not going
to double in the next 10 well that's
what they were saying 10 years ago and
that's what they were saying 10 years
before that I know because I remember
and what most people do is most people
get really excited when house prices are
going up and they go oh wow and they buy
but then after an expansion we know
comes a recession and then the house
Falls and then they go oh my gosh and
they sell and they lose money what you
want to do is you wanna buy low
and then wait for them to go oh and then
when it goes up and it's doubled in
value then you could sell but if you
sell you're going to pay capital gains
tax and instead you're going to
re-finance
and you're going to remember that when
you buy a house I bought a house in 2009
and it dropped and everyone was saying
ah it dropped it dropped but it was
making me a thousand pounds a month so
it's not about the price of the house
because the price of the house will
fluctuate what's really important is the
rent the truth is no one knows for sure
what house prices are gonna do over the
coming months and years we can look at
history and we can say well we've got a
shortage of housing we've got an
overpopulation of people in the UK which
is my main investment area I can say
it's a very small island it's a very
famous island where people want to live
here so I can say I'm pretty comfortable
knowing that over time house prices and
land in the UK are certainly going to
hold their value really well however I
don't know if house prices are going to
go up or if they're going to go down in
the next six 12 months for sure they
might go up they might go down it
depends on so many different factors if
interest rates drop a little bit then
suddenly more people want to start
buying and the more people want to start
buying it pushes house prices up if
interest rates go up a bit more it might
have the opposite effect and that's just
one factor there's hundreds of different
factors and some of them are unforeseen
but what I do know is over time house
prices are going to hold their value and
they're going to be a good long-term
investment
while I do have control over in the
short term though is if I buy a house
now will that house bring me in a
positive monthly cash flow or not that's
the thing that you want to really focus
on if you're buying property treating it
like Bitcoin or buy it and then watch
and hope it goes up in value in the next
six months now you need to sit on it and
wait but you need to make sure that
every month the rent is more than
covering the interest mortgage payments
and you're in good positive cash flow
and some really smart ways to do this
how to rent out properties as short stay
let's I'm investing a lot in Holiday
let's at the moment because you can get
instead of renting a property up for a
thousand pounds a month you might be
able to rent the property out for a
thousand pounds a week and you can
really push the monthly cash flow up or
renting your property out as a HMO a
house in multiple occupancy or maybe
turning a cheap property into a much
more expensive property and renting out
on a commercial lease we've got fixed
rent for 10 20 years so for me when I'm
buying property see I'm not obsessing
over what's going to happen in the next
three six months to house prices I know
that if I sit on it long enough it's
gonna hold its value it's gonna go up in
value it's going to be get rich slow but
I need to make sure when I'm buying is
Cash flowing positive right now that's
the most important thing of buying a
property so I'd love to know your
thoughts do you think now is a good time
to invest in property I think that it is
someone once said the best time to plant
a tree was 20 years ago but the second
best time was today and I think the
shame is true of property you can look
back and say I wish I'd bought 20 years
ago I mean what most people do most
people maybe watch a Samuel Lee's video
and they're thinking is now the time to
get into property and they're watching
the market and the market drops a little
bit and they think oh I'm glad I didn't
buy and then it goes up and they get
excited and it keeps going up and they
get excited and then it drops and if it
won't glad I didn't buy and then it goes
up again
and then oh you know article 4 section
106 it starts dropping interest rates
and then it goes up and then it drops
and then they die never having invested
in property waiting waiting waiting
waiting someone once said don't wait to
buy property buy property and wait and
of all the Investments gold silver
Bitcoin business stocks shares pensions
Isis I think that if you look at the
Sunday Times rich list and if you look
at what the actual really rich people
are investing in 90 of them seem to be
investing in real estate in property why
because they know that property is not
only a great investment for the short
term but also a great investment for the
long term safe as houses as they say I'd
love to any thoughts comment below I'm
investing in property right now heavily
what are you doing let me know in the
comments and I'll see you next time
thank you
[Music]